God bless
you just take us
damn
[ __ ] crazy good so much how are you
I'm good I'm good I'm just in town for
like 24 hours so I'm a little like
out of practice I'm on a red carpet with
lots of people in my practice I know
right yeah we don't do this often
anymore last year with what sort of
space out of like wow exactly you know I
know how personal this project was to
you so now to get the Atta girls for it
how is that feeling it feels so nice you
know
um my production company Freckle films
was involved in making it and George
it's based on Georgette Jones's book
that's George and Tammy's daughter Josh
Brolin approached me at the Golden
Globes over a decade ago and said you
should play Tammy Wynette are you
serious yeah so it's a long time in the
making and uh I'm just so happy to be
here I can't believe I'm a little
shocked I mean we had just premiered our
first episode when the nominations came
out so I just I'm shocked and I hope it
brings more attention to the show yeah
now you know the Globes is a party
because you've been here before yeah
it's a party yeah are you gonna have
you're only here for 24 hours Where Are
You Gonna Make It Count oh yeah I'm not
sleeping I love you it's a part it's a
full on good time well let's have a
little good time can I start you off
with a toast
yes this is me
this is for Miss Chastain cheers to you
always
you do this dress who is
like honestly it's a work of art well
you know
A girl's gotta do what a girl's gotta do
you know like is that all hand beaded
yeah I'm pretty sure I mean it's it's
heavy it's like a suit of armor I mean I
bet someone could punch me right here
and I wouldn't it would hurt them more
than me is there a corset in there or
like more than no I'm sucking my stomach
in so much I'm gonna pass out